my dad inspired me to be an entrepreneur
because he himself was an entrepreneur
so he had a
great job at a major corporation in
nigeria but then he decided one day to
give that up and pursue starting his own
business and so that inspired me to
become an entrepreneur he was also a
risk taker you know the very fact that
he sort of gave up the comfort of a
stable job to
start his own business and he was
incredibly hard working right so i
vividly remember many late nights in
which he was working into the night and
uh all that really inspired me to become
an entrepreneur
what's interesting about hundley is is
from the outside it almost seemed to
come out of nowhere because tophead
funded it himself he bootstrapped it and
then all of a sudden it was worth three
billion dollars last year with the
latest venture round
you know so that's that was really
interesting it was sort of like the same
way that mailchimp which is also an
atlantic company had come out of nowhere
in that way so at this point calendly is
quite a substantial company it has over
400 people over 100 million in revenue
and it could double its revenue again
this year so tope is a new billionaire
this year on the list he's worth 1.4
billion based on his majority stake in
the company and that's after the 10
discount that forbes takes on all
privately held company shares
the idea for the company came from a
frustrating experience i had trying to
schedule a meeting so i was looking to
schedule a very important customer
meeting and you know many many days
later and many many emails later we
still were no closer to finding a time
this inspired me to really learn about
the problem of scheduling and why it was
so difficult and out of that
sort of investigation came this
obsession with solvent scheduling since
then the product has evolved into more
than scheduling into sort of what we
call automating the median life cycle so
automating the the key tasks that happen
during the preparation and follow-up of
the meeting so that our customers can
have great obedience
one of the lessons i learned very early
on in starting businesses is that first
thing you want to do is when you see a
problem take action rather than wait for
somebody else to solve a problem there's
no reason why you can't take a stab at
solving it yourself and so action is
important but i also learned that really
having a differentiated approach right
what is going to be different about your
product or service what is going to be
different about the way you go to market
and and sell it and
price it right all those things are
really important so it's important to
have do a lot of customer discovery make
sure you really understand the customers
and the problem and have a unique
approach to solving the problem
i think what's interesting about him is
he's this super smart guy but he's also
a little bit different than some
founders because
he didn't really care about having
venture money he didn't really care
about some of the external things but
was focused on
calendly and how to make it work and he
really also just believed in himself in
the way that he threw everything into it
you know he spent down his 401k he flew
into ukraine while it was having its
earlier conflict in order to get uh
software engineers there to develop the
first product he bet everything on this
company
being nigerian means you grew up in a in
an environment in which there's a lot of
economic instability there's also a lot
of political instability and so what
ends up happening is a lot of nigeria's
incredibly resourceful people and when i
look at the success of countless today i
think some of that resourcefulness has
been a huge part of our success
i bootstrapped the company which means i
started the company with my own funds so
capital is very limited in the early
days but i actually attribute this
limited capital to the company's success
today the reason is it forced us to
focus wisely it also focuses to really
understand problems at a deep level
which meant that we could implement
simple effective solutions to solve the
problem
you know i'm really proud of the fact
that last year we crossed 100 million
dollars in revenue that was a huge
milestone for us because if you rewind
back to 10 years ago nobody really knew
that there was a there was a massive
problem to be solved here and the fact
that we've done that has been really
really exciting
[Music]
you